Greetings, hot Satan lovers, and welcome to
episode 4 of "American Horror Story: Apocalypse",
where we take a deep dive into the episode and
explore some of the mysteries and theories within.
So fold your towels and clean your
crock pots, ladies and gentlemen,
we're in for one hell of a ride.
The episode begins with Tatan - that's Satan +
Tate - recounting his childhood with robot mom.
But in all actuality, this is his real
mother who Mead is based off.
They say a prayer to the Dark Lord before
starting their meal and end it by saying NEMA,
which is Amen spelled backwards.
Notice Langdon's hair here looks
awfully like Tate's from season 1,
also hinting that his real mother is
somehow connected with Jessica Lange.
She explains that she killed her first
three husbands for the insurance policies.
And it's just great to see a beautiful mother-son
bonding moment over prayers to the Dark Lord
and talk of murder.
Behind her is a picture of Baphomet -
I'm probably butchering that name -,
a symbol supposedly worshipped by
the Knights Templar in the late 1300s,
which was later adopted by the Satanist Movement.
In the 1800's occultist Aleister Crowley
referred to Baphomet as the Divine Androgyne,
an androgynous being
composed of both male and female parts.
Which hints at Michael Langdon who, if you remember when he's questioned by Venable in episode 2,
hints that he might not actually be a man.
We'll come back to this point in a bit.
Back in real time, Langdon tells Mead that
he needs someone to help rebuild this world
and Mead, for the first time,
feels like she's found her place.
She's come a long way in just a few minutes,
but that's when Langdon senses the witches.
We're back where we left off with Cordelia
having risen Mallory, Dinah and Coco.
They were under an identity spell, which
Cordelia put on them for their own protection.
Because they're special and she
needs them for the upcoming war.
Dinah isn't having it and Madison tells her, "As if you
could defeat anyone with that backwards voodoo shit",
hinting that she is somehow related to
Marie Laveau's voodoo witchcraft from season 3.
Langdon confronts them and tells them they can't win,
before Myrtle reveals that he is a warlock.
But is he?
We'll get into that in a bit.
We then flash back three years to Warlock Hogwarts.
Kids chant, "Igneme accende",
Latin meaning "to burn or ignite".
A level 1 student arrives late and is chastised by
Behold Chablis, one of the teachers at the school.
We'll learn that there are four levels
of warlock, level 1 being the weakest.
Chablis tells the student if he's late he'll wind up at the Magic Castle doing card tricks like Neil Patrick Harris,
a nod to Neil's character in season 4
"Freak Show", where he plays a magician.
They also chant "ex forma
mutate, facti sunt figura nova",
which is Latin for "Change form, become a new shape".
Chablis tells them their power's woven into their DNA.
Does that mean Timmy and Emily, who
were told they have special DNA in episode 1,
are also witch and warlock?
They turn a bunch of perfectly
good gems into an aluminum ball,
making it the easiest aluminum ball challenge.
"Look how big this thing is right now!"
The scientist from Jurassic Park comes in
and tells Chablis they've been summoned.
Here, we meet the two other teachers,
John Henry Moore and the Grand Chancellor Ariel,
who is, coincidentally, named after an archangel.
The teachers watch a video of Langdon
training the world's greatest contortionist
while discussing his powers.
Are his powers his own or are they
more demonic, as John Henry suggests.
The warlocks, we learn, are not evil. In fact,
they don't even want dark energy around them.
Ariel suggests this boy could be the one the
prophecy suggested, the one they've been looking for.
The Alpha, the warlocks' version of a Supreme.
A being so powerful, he'd be able to
pass the test of the Seven Wonders,
the same test Zoe, Madison, Misty and
Queenie undergo in the finale of season 3.
If his powers are real, he could supplant the Supreme.
Ariel springs Langdon from
jail and tells him he's a warlock.
Langdon tells him he got in jail for defending
his mother when we get this lovely flashback:
Mrs. Satan wants a goat's head for incantations
and accuses the butcher of
discrimination for her religious beliefs.
This also happened in real
life when a group of Satanists
attempted to put a statue of
Baphomet next to the Ten Commandments,
and when they were told to take it down,
said it was religious discrimination.
Langdon does his best Arthur meme and uses his telekinetic power to stab the guy with butcher knives.
The irony of a butcher being butchered.
Ariel tells Michael his life's about to begin and
uses his warlock power to open the cell door.
They're stopped by an officer, but
Ariel uses his powers once again.
He's innocent of all charges. I'm taking him with me.
They escape, but Langdon kills the
officer, hinting the malevolence within him.
Mead is there somehow, knowing
her boy will make her proud someday.
Ariel explains that in 2014, Cordelia
outed the magic users to the world.
They became discriminated
and had to move underground,
because locals threw
Molotov cocktails into their school.
Michael's welcome, but it looks
like John Henry still has his doubts.
One month in, Langdon is evaluated by the warlocks.
He is to be assigned his level, and
we learn the teachers are all level 3.
A level 4 would make them
as powerful as the female Supreme,
and there's never been a level 4 warlock.
The level 1 test involves scrying, the
ability to see things on a reflective surface.
He must find a book, "The New Adam
and Eve" by Nathaniel Hawthorne,
a story about how after the destruction of Earth,
God created a new Adam and Eve to start over.
He's tasked to find out where the book was hidden,
but goes one step further and
actually retrieves it from the mirror.
The next task involves "salire per
spatium", Latin for "jump through space".
He is easily able to dodge the brick
and knife and is found on the ceiling,
just like the rubber man in episode 2.
Finally, "stiricidium", or "snowfall".
Not only is he able to conjure
snow, but something takes over him.
The wind and cold becomes too
unbearable for Baldwin, who can't breathe.
Ariel stops him and is pleased.
If he can learn to control these powers,
there's no limit to how high he can soar.
At dinner, the teachers talk about Langdon
being the most powerful warlock they've ever seen.
They're grooming him to take on the witches.
Only John Henry is the one who has doubts.
There's malevolence to his magic, leading
me to believe he is not the Alpha nor a warlock.
His powers stem from Satan
himself. He's a false prophet.
Also, if you can do this, sign me up for warlock school.
They then toast to the moment everything changes.
We're back in the coven,
bitches, and Zoe is now a teacher.
Mallory is one of the students and
turns the rose into blue butterflies.
Zoe even says her bloodline
goes all the way back to Salem,
Salem being the location of the
infamous witch trials of the late 1600s,
in which over 600 young women were accused of
being witches, 19 of them executed by hanging.
Myrtle informs Cordelia and Zoe that the
warlocks have called an emergency council meeting
at the Hawthorne School for Exceptional Young Men.
The same last name of the author of the book
Langdon was tasked to retrieve in the scrying test.
At the council meeting, Ariel explains
that the boy's powers are so impressive,
they matched those of the Supreme.
The witches scoff and Cordelia
reminds him that in all of history,
no man has ever approached the level of Supreme.
Men aren't equal to women
when it comes to magical ability.
Testosterone is a known inhibitor
impeding access to the ethereal realm.
Once again hinting that Langdon
is not male, or at least not fully.
Ariel wants the witches to
administer the test of the seven wonders,
but Cordelia won't do it because
she'd be condemning this boy to his death.
After all, she lost Misty by
administering the test too early.
And let's all say a big hello to Queenie, who's been trapped in the hotel Cortez, the setting for season 5.
She's been in a never-ending card game with
March, a serial killer and builder of the Cortez.
Cordelia explains that the hotel wasn't haunted,
rather it was a doorway to Hell where the devil reigns.
Her spells were useless in that hotel, hinting
that when the witches fight the demonic forces,
their spells won't work or will be severely weakened.
Cordelia's efforts to save Queenie end in failure,
and she considers it her worst failure as Supreme.
As the supreme in charge of caring for all
people, meaning both the witches and warlocks,
she denies giving the test to
Langdon, fearing his safety.
Ariel says she's just scared of the Alpha,
the one to bring the end of female domination.
A role reversal what's going on in society today:
the push for equality, the MeToo movement,
and even Cordelia using the phrase "Time is up".
But in this world, the females are dominant
and the men are the ones striving for equality.
Langdon is possessed and draws the hotel Cortez.
Something is taking control
of him, beckoning him there.
And soon we see him come to the rescue of
Queenie, to do what her Supreme couldn't.
March seems to sense his power, probably
because he knows what's controlling Michael.
He immediately knows she won't
be back, saying, "Solitaire it is".
Able to get her out, Langdon
says there's one person left to get.
Madison works customer
returns in her own eternal Hell.
She's undervalued, overworked
and, worst of all, unrecognized.
She's even cattle prodded by her boss Randall.
I even loved the neverending line of her turns.
Langdon comes to claim her
soul and save her from this Hell.
Madison hoes it up, telling him he's a snack
and how terrible that they're always
out of stock of personal massagers
before Queenie arrives to convince Madison to come.
There's work to do and he needs both of them.
But what he really needs is to prove a point:
that his abilities are extremely powerful.
Langdon arrives with Madison
and Queenie and let me just say,
for people who have just returned from
the netherworld, they look fine as hell.
Cordelia faints as the witches reunite,
Langdon basking in the knowledge he
was able to do what the others could not.
So what can we expect from the next few episodes?
We'll likely see two separate timelines:
One, the past, learning how Langdon took over as
Alpha and witnessing the birth of the Cooperative.
And two, the current timeline, the
battle between the witches and Satan.
Will Michael bring back Misty and will
John Henry Moore defect to the witches?
We'll have to stay tuned for next episode.
Hey everyone, I hope you liked this video.
If you enjoyed it, please give it a like and subscribe.
I'm planning on doing the whole
season, so I hope you'll stick with me.
I also have a new Twitter, where you can find
my video release schedule or just ask me questions.
So give me a follow @ThinkStoryYT.
And last but not least:
Daddy loves you very much.